what we have here is a visual depiction
of a function
and this is a depiction of y is equal to
h of x now when a lot of people see
function notation like this they can
they see it as somewhat intimidating
until you realize what it's saying all a
function is is something that takes an
input in this case it's taking x as an
input and then the function does
something to it and then it spits out
some other value which is going to be
equal to y
so for example what is h of 4
based on this graph that you see right
over here pause this video and think
through that well all h of 4 means is
when i input 4 into my function h
what y am i spitting out or another way
to think about it when x is equal to 4
what is y equal to
well when x is equal to 4
my function spits out that y is equal to
3. we know that from this point right
over here so y is equal to 3 so h of 4
is equal to 3.
let's do another example
what is
h
of 0
pause the video try to work that through
well all this is saying is is if i input
x equals 0 into the function
what is going to be the corresponding y
well x when x equals 0 we see that y is
equal to
4. so it's as simple as that
given the input what is going to be the
output and that's what these points
represent each of these points represent
a different output for a given input now
it's always good to keep in mind one of
the things that makes it a function is
that for given x that you input you only
get one y
for example if we had two dots here
then all of a sudden we or we have two
dots for x equals six now all of a
sudden we have a problem at figuring out
what h of six would be equal to because
it could be equal to 1 or it could be
equal to 3. so if we had this extra dot
here then this would no longer be a
function in order for it to be a
function for any given x it has to
output a unique value it can't output
two possible values
now the other way is possible it is
possible to have two different x's that
output the same value for example if
this was circled in what would h of
negative 4 be well h of negative 4 when
x is equal to negative 4 when you put
that into our function it looks like the
function would output 2. so h of
negative 4 would be equal to 2.
but h of 2
is also equal to we see very clearly
there when we input a 2 into the
function the corresponding y value is 2
as well
so it's okay for two different x values
to map to the same y value that works
but if you had some type of an
arrangement some type of a relationship
where for given x value you had two
different y values then that would no
longer be a function but the example
they gave us is a function assuming i
don't modify it